states across America move toward
reopening Democrats reveal big plans for
America's reshaping and Joe Biden tries
to talk to a recording I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show today's
show is sponsored by expressvpn my savvy
fans secure their Internet you should to
join them and expressvpn dot-com / Ben
alrighty so the big discussion that
seems to be happening nationwide about
how to reopen it is now moving state to
state and a lot of blue states are
moving toward reopening so all the talk
about how if you want to reopen it's
just because you don't care about saving
human life it turns out that was all a
bunch of bullcrap and that everybody is
going to have to reopen at some point or
other and everybody is going to do so in
some fashion or other some place is
gonna lock down longer some places are
gonna lock down
shorter and then we're gonna have a fair
number of case studies as to who is
right and who is wrong one thing is
becoming eminently clear and that is the
economy simply cannot stay shut down
this way there is just no way for the
economy to stay shut down and the reason
that the economy cannot stay shut down
this way is because in the end as
president Trump originally suggested the
fact is that we will end up losing more
years of life if the economy is shut
down for a long period of time than we
would through coronavirus itself that by
the way comes courtesy of a study that's
being quoted in the week over at the UK
and they have an article there called
why the economic crash could cost more
lives than coronavirus the idea there
being of course that as people lose
their lives due to health conditions
brought on by poverty as people kill
themselves as people engage in opioid
overdoses that all of these things
factored in means that people are losing
significant years of their lives and so
when you actually measure lives lost it
is not just enough to measure lives lost
I've said this before and people have
gotten very upset with me the reality is
that when you make actuarial tables and
when you decide what how to how to set
policy there are a couple of stats that
are necessary one is how many lives on
just a pure simple of a lot of loss but
the second is how many quality adjusted
life years are lost meaning that if you
have one policy that kills a certain
number of 30 year-olds and one policy
that is likely to raise the risk for a
certain number of 81 year-olds you have
to take into account the difference in
quality adjusted life years for people
who are 30 in people who are 81 then in
fact if somebody dies at 30 they have
lost
life years than somebody who dies at 81
that does not mean that we should not
mitigate risk for people who are 81 it
duska me it does mean that when you make
a risk calculation about generalized
policy you do have to take that into
account well how bad is this thing
getting the Federal Reserve Bank on
Thursday reported that nearly 40% of
those with a household income below
$40,000 reported a job loss in March
okay that that that now becomes
effectively a permanent underclass I
mean that's an insane number forty
percent of people with a household
income below $40,000 reported a job loss
in March alone four out of ten at the
same time for the majority of adults
their income and ability to pay current
bills appeared to remain generally
stable during the initial weeks of the
corona virus pandemic also essentially
unchanged was the percentage of people
who reported they could pay off an
unexpected $400 emergency expense
entirely using cash savings or a credit
card at the next statement that is
because the government has been floating
everybody checks the findings back up
other reports that show that
lower-income Americans as well as black
and Hispanic people are bearing the
brunt of the outbreaks financial fallout
they're more likely to work in sectors
that are laying off or furloughing
workers such as food services more than
one in five Americans have filed initial
jobless claims since the pandemic began
according to the Federal Reserve CNN
reporting from the start of march
through April twenty twenty nineteen
percent of adults said they lost a job
were furloughed or had their hours
reduced some 64% of adults who reported
a job loss or reduction in hours
expected to be able to pay all their
bills in full in April compared to 85
percent of those without an employment
disruption but nine and ten people who
lost a job reported their an employer
indicated they would return to work than
their bosses did not say when that would
occur now one of the big problems is
that the Paycheck Protection Act has
created a bit of a catch-22 for a lot of
businesses you're supposed to retain 90
percent of your payroll however you're
only supposed to remain 25 or 50 percent
open for the duration so if you take the
loan the only way that that loan gets
forgiven is if you make your business
utterly unsustainable by paying
employees not to work effectively
speaking meanwhile the Paycheck
Protection Act and the and the consumer
and the cares Act the cares Act has made
it so that a huge number of American
workers actually make more money off of
the unemployment benefits being paid by
the federal government than they would
back in the regular jobs and that is a
problem as we move out of the pandemic
as we start to open up again I'm
people are just going to say okay well
you know what sure I'm young and healthy
sure my chance of dying from this are
extraordinarily small but you know what
I'm getting paid more to be on
unemployment is something Republicans
pointed out at the time and they were
completely right and the media mocked
them for it
according to five thirty eight.com the
estimated percentage of earnings
replaced by unemployment benefits for
the median unemployment were unemployed
worker in ten common occupational fields
is above a hundred percent for prettiman
is the median payment is above a hundred
percent that you will make from
unemployment for the following services
food service janitorial medical
assistance sales and retail
transportation construction and teachers
the only people who are who are earning
less from unemployment than they would
from their normal jobs are people who
are nurses and therapists managers and
people in informational technology so in
other words if you are not on the
unsorted the low-income scale then you
will make more by going back to work but
if you are on the low-income scale then
we're going to pay you not to work
according to these bills now in the
short term that at least makes some
sense in the sense that if you can't go
back to work then paying you not to work
makes some sense we don't want people
rushing back to work willy-nilly but as
states start to open up we have started
to see I've talked to people who are
employers who are saying I offered my
workers to stay at their jobs and they
don't want to come back because they're
getting paid more by the government not
to come back now at the same time this
has become a class issue because the
people who are most likely to tell you
that they want the government to remain
the payer for for all of this the people
most likely to tell you that they would
like these lock downs from an in place
forever are people in the mainstream
media who are not losing their jobs
Fareed Zakaria actually has pointed this
out over at the Washington Post Fareed
has a very good piece over there I'll
talk to you about it in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that now
is like a great time to take care of
your mind and body I mean the fact is
that a lot of people are down I hear you
a lot of people are getting depressed I
hear you but the the best and easiest
way to stave off that sort of feeling is
to get stronger mentally and physically
as well and Noom helps you do this Noom
is the habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses based in psychology
neun teaches you why you do the things
you do empowers you with the tools you
need to break bad have a turn replace
them with better ones Noom doesn't tell
you what to do and what not to do
instead it teaches you how to look
inside your own mind and make better
decisions for your
so anybody who has ever dyed it
understands that it doesn't work if you
consider a temporary you have to
actually make some significant lifestyle
changes for the duration Numa helps you
change all the bad habits that drove you
to be where you are now and turns you
into a stronger better human being when
it comes to fighting off those cravings
and reshaping your lifestyle you don't
have to change everything in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at noon that's noe
m.com slash shapiro again that's Noom
comm slash up here to start your trial
today n om accom slash shapiro go check
them out right now I've been using them
for a while and there's a reason I've
taken off some weight during this
pandemic Noom comm / Shapiro
okay so Fareed Zakaria has a good piece
on the class differences between the
people who are calling for lockdown and
the people who are saying that we need
to get back to work and I will say that
there is one other distinction there are
a lot of people who are business owners
who are saying we need to get back to
work even if they're high income earners
so a lot of high income earners who are
just sitting at home and the pandemic is
basically as comedian Patton Oswalt
suggested wow it's so tough you're
watching Netflix all day turns out there
are a lot of people we're not watching
Netflix all day turns out that a lot of
people who are struggling to put food on
the table it turns out there are tons of
people who own businesses who are
struggling to figure out how to pay
their employees and how to keep their
businesses afloat and how to keep their
life savings from being drained away
Fareed Zakaria has a good piece on this
over at the Washington Post he says many
people are wondering why partisanship
has become so strong in the United
States that people will not listen to
experts even at the risk of their own
health but there's a broader distrust we
need to understand these I recognize
that while reading a book that is not
about covert 19 at all but sheds strong
light on the situation
explaining why so many people across the
west have rejected the government
establishment michael lind writes the
issue is not the issue issues power
social power exists in three realms
government the economy and the culture
each of these three realms of social
power is the site of class conflict now
he attributes this to economic conflict
it's really more cultural Lynne's new
book the new class war argues that the
best way to understand America today is
through the lens of class conflicts
which has been sharpened by the rise of
an over class that dominates the three
spheres he mentions in all three leaders
tend to be urban college educated
professionals often with a postgraduate
degree that makes them quite distinct
from the rest of the country only 36% of
Americans have a bachelor's degree only
13% of a master's or more and yet the
top echelon is everywhere our field are
filled with this credential to overclass
hiss when he says his class distinction
he doesn't actually mean in an economic
class distinction he means that it
a class distinction as far as people who
have gone to university people who are
generally secular people who have a
particular worldview about the role of
government and who happened to be in
charge of a lot of major industries a
lot of cultural totems and this is
something that's not new to Michael Lynn
and charles murray was talking about
this in his book coming apart fifteen
years ago but says Fareed Zakaria from
any non college-educated people
especially those living in rural areas
there's a deep alienation from this new
elite and see the overclass as enacting
policies presented as good for the whole
country but really mostly benefit people
from the ruling class whose lives have
gotten better over the past few decades
while the rest are left behind in this
view trade and immigration helped
college-educated professionals who work
from multinational corporations but hurt
blue-collar workers so when they hear
from experts about the inevitability of
globalization and technological change
in the need to accept it they resist
because it does not resonate with their
lived experience he says let's look at
the Cova nineteen crisis through this
prism imagine you're an American who
works with his hands and you just lost
your job because of the lockdowns has
him more than 36 million people he
turned on the TV and your medical
experts academics Technic rats and
journalists explain we have to keep the
economy closed because public health is
important in other words keep you
unemployed all these people making the
case have jobs have maintained their
standards of living in fact are now in
greater demand they feel as though they
are doing important work you on the
other hand of lost your job you feel a
sense of worthlessness you're terrified
about your family's day-to-day survival
is it so hard to understand why people
like this might be skeptical of the
experts this is correct for exact or I
really hits the nail on the head right
here and you can see that the media do
not get it the media the people of media
do not understand this and they have no
reason to understand this because people
in media again get to do what I do right
I thank God I have a good life right I
can do my show from the safety of my
home I still get my paycheck but I
understand that there are tens of
millions of Americans who do not and
that is why I think it is imperative
that they be allowed to make their own
choices they can make their own
individual risk assessments than some
jackass on CNN what better than I can
and I'm not saying that I should make
the risk assessment for you I'm saying
you should make the risk assessment for
you and it is the job of the so-called
experts to provide you information so
you can make your own independent risk
assessment and this is why it is so
utterly unhelpful when the media refused
to report to you actual information
instead just giving you anecdotally
there's a piece in The New York Times
yesterday by Mara gay who's the head of
the
16:19 project and very well-respected
columnist at the New York Times by the
left hey Mara gay got kovat 19 and she
got very very sick from it and so she
has an entire piece about how sick she
got from it and the entire premise of
the piece is young people are getting
seriously ill from koban 19 nowhere in
the entire piece does she cite a
statistic saying how many young people
are getting sick from Cove in 19 now
it's important to know for people what
Cova 19 is like that is important and
I'm extremely happy that Mara gay is
feeling better I'm you know god forbid
anybody should get sick and die with
kovat 19 but it is very important that
if you are running the world's most
quote-unquote respected newspaper you
actually at some point in an article
like that give me the number so I can
assess my own risk I understand that if
somebody gets hit side on in a car crash
but that's going to be really bad and
that the recovery time is gonna be
really bad I need to know when I go out
the door in the morning what are my odds
of being hit side long in a car crash
because I'm making my own risk
assessment all media information should
be geared toward giving Americans enough
information that they can make their own
risk assessment and most media
information is not geared toward that
most media information is geared sort of
certain level of alarmism and a level of
distrust with the American public and
ironically what ends up happening is
that people respond to the media by then
saying okay the entire thing is BS now
I'm hearing from some conservatives this
about for example face masks wearing
people suggesting on the conservative
side there are a few people on the
conservative side I would say who say
you know what I don't want to wear a
face mask because the experts have been
wrong all the time and they just want to
control my Liberty and I've said no face
mask wearing is probably a good idea
prevents other people from getting it
it's not to protect you is to protect
everybody who is around you and if the
goal is to slow the spread enough that
we don't spike over the healthcare
systems capacity and if the goal is to
go back to work in fast in fast moving
action then wearing face masks is a
great way of preventing all this right
in many countries it is mandatory and it
is not you signing away your Liberty to
say that you're gonna wear a face mask
it is you saying that you care about
your neighbors that you're gonna wear
the face mask until some better
therapeutic is found or until we trans
population such that herd immunity is
pursuable but you have to understand
that for a lot of people they look at
the experts who are telling them that
the best option is for them to stay
inside forever and those same experts
are yelling at people not wearing face
masks and so you get exactly the sort of
political polarization we've seen in the
country which is people responding to
each other not responding to information
now in the media make themselves
character in this story when the media
is entire narrative is we stands up for
lockdowns because we care about your
life and then they provide you no
information then people are gonna say
well I care about my life more than you
care about my life and I care about my
freedom more than you care about my
freedom so I'm just gonna discount
whatever you say and so there-there is
that natural reaction because the media
do have this disconnect with the
American people at this point they are
not trying to bring Americans the
information the instead are trying to
push an agenda you can see that most
clearly when it comes to the
state-by-state
lock-down attitudes of the media we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that in this
job market it is imperative that
employers be able to connect with
prospective employees as fast and as
easily and as efficiently as possible
and if you are a prospective employee
you want to get the job listing as fast
as possible and apply to the job that
fits you the best
this is where a zip recruiter comes in
they were doing important work before it
has never been more important than right
now if you are looking for a job know
that zipper career is working with you
to find the right job faster zip
recruiter is dedicated to helping you
get hired whether you're looking for
jobs in caretaking delivering food and
goods building medical facilities
supplying protective equipment and so
much more in fact zip recruiters at
Apple send you up-to-date job openings
so you can be one of the first to apply
if you're actively hiring zip recruit
we'll invite candidates to apply to your
most urgent roles making it faster and
easier to reach the people that you need
now connecting people who need jobs and
companies that need people zip recruiter
is moving the country forward through a
very difficult time go use zip recruiter
right now it's gonna be good for your
business and if you're a prospective
employee it's gonna be good for your job
options go check out zip recruiter right
now zipper career.com slash work
together that's what they're helping us
to zip recruiter comm slash work
together to find the best employee or
find the best employer or zip recruiter
comm slash work together okay so the
media simply don't get this they simply
don't understand why people are angry at
them so yesterday there's a clip going
around by a guy named Kevin VC and it
has you know six million hits on Twitter
and this video basically shows this
person walking around a rally where
people are rallying for opening and
people are yelling at the media they're
saying you guys don't understand what
we're going through you guys are you
guys are attempting to portray us as
coops and nuts from wanting to reopen
and going back to our work you're
suggesting that we want to get people
killed
you can yep go screw off take it take a
long walk off a short pier here's what
that videos
sounds like you stopped airing the Trump
briefings that you keep airing Cuomo
briefings cause we know you want to keep
your job we get it you're not getting
used to people by the way our wearing
facemasks most of them are socially
distancing they're holding signs saying
things like coronavirus is not going
away but our jobs are that is a fair
argument right there and by the way the
Rick bright who is who is the the doctor
who was supposedly fired from the Trump
administration yesterday he literally
said about vaccines you guys are being
too optimistic about vaccines you're
saying 12 to 18 months it could be two
years it could be three years right
that's the guy the media we're trotting
out yesterday don't they understand that
undermines their argument for locking
down forever because that is completely
impossible and implausible the media do
not understand why people are so angry
at them again it's because you stopped
providing us information and you've
started providing us your opinion on the
information and that's okay right I'm an
opinion show I tried to provide you the
information first but I'm very clear
about my opinion and I tried to state
what my agenda is upfront and then you
can make your own decision but what you
are seeing from the media is not that
you're seeing their quote-unquote
objective journalists who are very angry
that people can see their bias and are
recognizing that the media are not
actually providing us information so
last night for example Anderson Cooper
on CNN he was very very angry he's very
angry talents from jr. why because
people were making fun of CNN for
hosting Greta fun Berg on a CNN Town
Hall about coronavirus because we're
like what the hell does Greta Thun Berg
know about coronavirus and well why is
Greta Thun Berg on like what what level
of expertise can she provide and so
apparently she was there to talk about
the fact that she had donated $100,000
from her fun for a coronavirus funding
or something okay well then why don't
you have on you know first of all I know
personally many people who have given
more money than that to the coronavirus
fight and are spending more of their own
money out of their own pocket in order
to try and do something about this
and those people happen to know more
than a 17 year old girl most
for shouting at adults but Anderson
Cooper was very upset with you Arif sit
down junior fair upset with anybody who
had questions CNN's bonafide he's in
bringing on a 17 year old girl most
famous for shouting at adults in a
Swedish accent they blew check on
Twitter saw the initial ad and was
outraged and claimed that we had booked
Greta tomba to be an expert on a
coronavirus panel with other health
experts then of course
Donny crumb jr. jumped into this which
is weird because I thought he was
allegedly running whatever range of the
Trump Organization I mean shouldn't that
be like a really busy job since it's you
know Electra Lee such a great big
company anyway once TJ TJ started typing
than other people with blue checks on
Twitter also started doing their thing
because everyone has to produce content
these days that's what it's all about
it's like a tween on tick-tock a tween
on take tack that would pretty much
describe a lot of CNN coverage between
on tick-tock would describe Chris Cuomo
walking out of his basement on cameras
though that's providing us any useful
information other than the reality TV
drama of the whole thing okay so again
that's why the people are angry at the
media and it's also why there's new
information that Americans are
increasingly just not paying attention
to a lot of the information that the
that the so-called experts are providing
and when I say so-called experts I don't
mean foul Qi I mean people like Anderson
Cooper and Don Lemon and the rest if
fact is by the way that there is a new
poll out showing that social distancing
is dropping dramatically and as I've
said this is gonna be led from the
bottom up people are just gonna say I'm
not doing this anymore 58 percent right
now of Americans say they're completely
or mostly self isolating that is down
from 75 percent the decline is in states
both with and without stay at home
orders so it is not just Florida it is
not just Georgia the media are trying to
blame certain states but not other
states and it is amazing to watch this
because they don't actually seem to be
looking at the results of states that
are reopening they don't seem to be
looking at differential results instead
they have the agenda and the agenda is
driving the media coverage so here is a
couple perfect examples political
finally is paying attention to the fact
that Ron DeSantis did not blow it in
Florida so Politico has an entire
article titled Florida man beats Kovan
for now right the implication being that
maybe Ron de Santa still did the wrong
thing but finally they're actually
admitting this they say first let's just
come out and say it
DeSantis looks more right than those who
criticize the sunshine states
coronavirus response
you know you can you can always tell
immediately what the angle is I guess we
have to admit it right mark Caputo and
Renuka rai assam over a politico first
let's just come out and say it I guess
we'll have to admit it you wouldn't have
to admit it if you just covered this
thing fairly in the first place if you
just recognize that what the scientists
did was perfectly in line with pandemic
response over time namely treat areas
differentially recognize that large
outdoor areas where people are not
congregated are not the place where this
thing is spreading according to Politico
according to the latest Florida figures
fewer than 2,000 have died around 43
thousand have been infected as a
fraction of the dire predictions made
from Florida when spring breakers
swarmed the beaches and those numbers
are dwarfed by similarly sized in New
York which has seen 12 times more deaths
and nearly eight times more infections
more people reportedly died in New York
nursing homes than in all of Florida
they say good evening and greetings from
Florida where we feel the need to inform
you it's not a post-apocalyptic
hellscape of coronavirus infection and
cadavers stacked like cordwood that is
Florida just doesn't look nearly as bad
as the national news media and skies
falling critics have been predicting for
about two months now but then the
national news media is mostly based in
New York and loves to love its
democratic Governor Andrew Cuomo about
as much as it loves to hate on Florida's
Republican governor Ron de santis
correct correct and then you wonder why
we don't trust the media because they're
not providing this information they're
just providing us angles this is why
DeSantis is pulling worse than Cuomo in
his home state which is insane
Florida handled this right and New York
is a garbage heap Cuomo is the worst
governor in America Politico says part
of that is style Cuomo has a smooth
delivery a deep and calming voice and an
attitude that projects he can answer any
question well that certainly makes up
for the fact that he was shoving old
people with Cova 19 back into nursing
homes I can certainly see why the media
fell for that gag it truly is incredible
political does acknowledge there is
media bias they say Cuomo also has
something else just ANSYS doesn't
depress that defers to him one that
prefers to cover quote-unquote Florida
morons at the beach where it's
relatively hard to get infected over New
Yorkers riding cramped subway cars where
it's easy to get infected in people in
fact people can still ride the subways
most hours of the day in New York but my
Miami Beach's sands remain closed maybe
things would be different if DeSantis
had a brother who worked in cable news
and interviewed him for a sweet moment
in primetime correct it just took you
what two months to figure this out and
then you wonder why people don't trust
the media let's be real about this the
entire narrative here which is that
President Trump blew it and Democrats
are doing it right and those who push
lockdown
are winning and those who push opening
up are losing and want to sacrifice
people like George's human sacrifice
experiment that was all a bunch of crap
and I'm not gonna trust anybody who
tells me that that sort of stuff I
didn't trust them then I'm not gonna
trust them now instead I'm gonna assess
my own risk based on the information
that is provided to me and I think most
Americans feel the same way we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
right now is not the world's best time
to go to the auto parts store in fact
going to the auto parts store is usually
a waste of time instead what you should
be doing is using the interwebs why well
first you're gonna say buddy when you go
to Rock Auto calm because rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do well I spend up to twice as
much for the same parts rockauto.com is
a family business serving Auto Parts
customers online for twenty years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds manufacturers best
of all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts makes no sense this is
why the interweb exists Rock auto comm
catalog is unique remarkably easy to
navigate and to navigate quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need Rock Auto calm head
on over to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you again right shapiro in there
how did you hear about a spot set so
they know we sent you go to rock Auto
calm right now that's Rock Auto calm
okay so here is the dirty little secret
the dirty little secret is that every
state is reopening to a certain extent
while there are states and places like
la that are insisting that nobody reopen
I've been out here on the roads people
are going to work ok bit there there is
traffic on the roads and this happens to
be true across the United States and the
more the authorities shout at people and
the more they they promote stupid policy
the more of that policy will get ignored
the if you actually want people to pay
attention your policy you have to
explain them why you're doing what you
are doing and why it makes any sense
this is true with children when you're
teaching children you actually have to
explain some the rationale for the rules
saying because I said so only works for
kids who are about three once they had
about five or six they actually want to
know why you are doing what you are
doing when you get to be full-grown
adult you don't just pay attention to
rules because you are told to do so
unless you are a stop unless you are a
SAP or a stop I mean the
there is no reason for you to pay
attention to rules unless those rules
are designed to do a thing or as I said
yesterday unless you're being bribed to
follow the rules or you're being
threatened to follow the rules and both
of those last two rationales are just
not sufficient because over time unless
that bribe is pretty steep you're not
gonna want to follow it and unless that
punishment is rigidly enforced you're
just going to ignore it
most people are not going to put on
masks at the beach ten feet away from
each other and never sit on the sand
because our stupid governor Gavin Newsom
said so here in California meanwhile in
Los Angeles for example they're saying
now that masks are mandatory when you go
outside for anyone above the age of two
I have a four-year-old son guess what
he's not going to be doing wearing a
mask and knowing that I'm not gonna put
him near an old person because I am a
responsible human being knowing that I'm
not going to put him near anybody who's
outside of my family right we're going
to continue social distancing but the
stricter you set the rules the fewer
people are going to obey the rules and
the more the rules get broken and then
the institution that promulgated the
rules loses its legitimacy an easy way
for an institution to lose its
legitimacy is to have people basically
ignore it this is true whether you're
the media or whether you are the
government but the media have this
narrative and they continue to push the
narrative despite the fact that again
places all over America are opening up
Democrat and Republican they're doing so
step by step and they're all following
the Florida model right they're doing so
in gradual fashion they're doing so with
levels of social distancing and a fairly
heavy level of mass glaring but the way
the media portray this is that
Republicans want to willy-nilly let
everybody out of the box that they can
just go have kissing parties and kill
each other that's not true the media are
pushing this and this is why people are
ignoring them so Tony avers who is the
governor of Wisconsin or a Democratic
governor of Wisconsin the Supreme Court
of Wisconsin said that the government of
Wisconsin does not have authority for
the kind of lockdowns that they have
been doing certainly now with not
without legislative approval so after
the Supreme Court decision a lot of
Mayors came in with their own local
rules and those rules are basically
being obeyed but if you listen to Tony
Evers the governor of Wisconsin the mere
suggestion that he does not get to
willy-nilly lock down anything he wants
in any fashion he wants means that
Wisconsin has turned into the Wild West
it has not turned into the Wild West
remember there was all that talk about
how the Wisconsin Supreme Court decision
and that suggested that people had to
vote in person that you couldn't just
decide on this bird
moment that all voting was gonna be
mailing that was going to kill massive
numbers of Americans the grand total
number of Americans went out and voted
that day who got Co vat19 out of the
tens and maybe I think it was over a
hundred thousand people who voted in
Wisconsin that say the grand total
number of people who got a coven
nineteen infection and it's not even
obvious that it came from the voting
booths 52 we were told it was gonna kill
tens of thousands of people right that
if you go out to the voting booth in
your social year since everybody's gonna
die it turns out nope
here's Governor Tony Evers though
pushing the narrative accompanied by
Chris Cuomo who couldn't even who
couldn't even follow his own rules when
it came to socially distancing but he
expects all the rest of youto the
Republicans convinced forced afford of
Supreme Court justices that aid facts
don't matter if B the law doesn't matter
and see the precedents don't matter it
was a horrible decision not unexpected
not unexpected because clearly there
were there are four justices that were
looking for any way they could to kook
concur with Republican majority and in
the legislature so it happened and now
we have the Wild West it's not the Wild
West what the hell are you talking about
there's an article in The New York Times
about various states reopening today and
it talks about the reopening deepening
political divides they say in Wisconsin
residents woke up to a state of
confusion on Thursday after the
conservative majority on the state
Supreme Court sided with a Republican
majority in the legislature on Wednesday
night overturning a statewide stay at
home ordered by Governor Tony Evers a
Democrat in Michigan hundreds of
protesters many of them armed turned out
at the state capitol in a drenching
rainstorm in Pennsylvania some
Republican lawmakers urged defiance of
the Democratic governor's orders to keep
non-essential businesses closed and
president from flew to Allentown for a
politically charged visit to a medical
supply facility the response to the
corona virus in these three states which
determines the 2016 presidential
election and could strongly influence
the one in November is becoming a
confused and agitated blend of health
guidance protests and partisan politics
leaving residents to fend for themselves
okay I have a question when we say
isn't that generally what you call
freedom okay I don't mean that people
shouldn't be taken care of if they are
forced not to work by the government
that the government didn't drive on a
Ford f-150 through the front wall your
house and other government has to pay
but you know what we used to call being
left alone freedom okay
again not to suggest that people should
go out willy-nilly and start kissing
each other in the street that is to
suggest that you are best capable of
determining your own risk level you do
it every damn day
and because the baseline risk level has
risen and because depending on your
population tranche you may have risen
more for you you get to decide what is
the most risky you get to decide whether
you believe that the members of your
community are being responsible and
whether you are going to go out today
right this is just something it's your
decision basically across Wisconsin the
court ruling left some residents in a
festive mood heading directly to one of
the state's many taverns to celebrate
others were determined to stay home word
it was to students returned to crowded
restaurants and chops says the New York
Times but here's the reality
despite all of this most americans are
continuing to be responsible most
americans are continuing to make
risk-averse decisions if they can do so
but the notion again is this this
partisan divide is is so deep that
basically it's one or the other either
you want to lock down and cower in fear
or you want to go out there without a
mask and you want to infect as many
people as humanly possible and you don't
care what happens next and that is just
not the way most Americans are
responding that's not there with and by
the way that is not the way that even
blue states are responding New Jersey is
about to open its beaches Jersey Shore
is going to be open now according to New
Jersey calm under governor Murphy's
executive order beaches and lake fronts
must limit the number of visits visitors
given access so people can properly
socially distance families in households
are allowed to cluster together
otherwise people need to be six feet
apart the opening goes into effect May
22nd the beginning of Memorial Day
weekend and the unofficial start of the
summer season Murphy said the Jersey
Shore after all is where memories are
made the last thing any of us wanted was
for a summertime down the shore to be a
memory but I thought that according to
Governor Phil Murphy just like Andrew
Cuomo any attempt to open anything was
going to end inevitably in more death
hey notice everybody's following the
same policies Democrats Republicans
Kentucky is now lifting its travel ban
Governor Andy Beshear over there who's a
Democrat is now lifting the travel ban
in Kentucky so blue states are doing
this here's Andy Beshear yesterday May
22nd is also when we're gonna let the
travel ban expire now the travel ban has
been very important to where we are and
to flattening the curve and we still
need to be very careful about where we
travel to if you are thinking about
to the beach right now it is still very
dangerous and remember there are
hundreds of cases in Western Kentucky
related to a trip to the beach but if
you have family that lives close by
that's coming in for Memorial Day
again you can socially distance they
don't fall into the vulnerable
categories you know that's that's it a
place that that we are now at and we're
seeing a number of these travel bans
expiring okay so even the Democrats are
saying you know what this is just not
workable and we are starting to reopen
and by the way the longer you tighten
people down the more people are going to
move from areas that are reasonable from
that are unreasonable to areas that are
reasonable in fact and you're starting
to see that trend that trend is very
real you're going to see I'm predicting
within the next year and a half you'll
see a rush from places like New York and
Los Angeles out to other places the
places that walk down the tightest are
the places that are going to squeeze the
air out of the balloon people are going
to leave I've talked to so many friends
in the past week alone who have talked
about moving out of LA and talk about
prominent people in the Los Angeles area
who have said this is ridiculous right
they're letting criminals out of jail
they won't let me go out of my house
without a mask and then if my house gets
robbed the police show up and tell me
they can't do anything so no and then
we're gonna get charged twice in taxes
because they're gonna have to fill in
whatever payroll gap they created
because they're crappy fiscal policies
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that right now is not a great time to go
to the post office but lots people
sending lots packages right now the mail
is one of the ways we stay in touch and
one of the ways we're getting business
done with so much retail closed with
Sam's comm you can print postage on
demand and skip the lines and crowds at
the post office plus you can actually
save some money with discounts you can't
even get at the post office as if that
wasn't enough stamps comm also offers
UPS services with discounts up to 62
percent and no UPS residential
surcharges here at say Lee Weyer we've
been using stamps calm since 2017 no
more wasting our time stamps.com brings
all the services of the US Postal
Service to wrecks your computer and the
safety and comfort of your own home
office anywhere else you are hunkering
down right now whether your small
business sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products or you're
just working from home and you need to
mail stuff stamps comm can handle all of
it with ease and like I said stamps comm
get great discounts to five cents off
every first-class stamp up to 62 percent
off shipping rates stamps Calm it's a no
brainer it's a no time
saves you money right now my listeners
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps comm click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro again that is stamps.com and
type in Shapiro after you click on that
microphone at the top of the homepage
alrighty well we're gonna get to more of
this in just one second it is amazing to
watch as the entire informational story
put out by the media turns out to have
been a complete lie this lie that there
is a harsh division between lockdown
States and non lockdown States and the
lockdown states we're going to benefit
non lockdown States we're all going to
die it turns out all of that was crap it
was not information only driven which
does leave you question why there are so
many politicians who continue to push it
and the answer of course is partisanship
we'll get to that in just one second
first got to tell you that it is that
time of the week that special time of
the week when we feature one of our
listeners one of our fans with the daily
wire tumbler the famed leftist ears
tumbler today we feature at sapore on
Twitter
keeping excellent companies during these
lockdown days in this picture an
adorable happy little baby boy is
nestled in his rocker smiling for the
camera while holding the world's
greatest beverage vessel the caption
reads he can't wait to be on the podcast
with Uncle Ben he's never actually met
any family members anyway so we figured
we could include Ben Shapiro yeah I
appreciate it we're all family now
welcome to the family
don't give your mom any trouble and now
that I'm your uncle drunk of your uncle
any trouble either thanks for the pic
stay safe up there in New York I also
want to take a moment to tell you about
the daily wares newest most exclusive
membership tear all access the all
access membership tier it's our premier
level of membership all excess members
get to participate in all access live
this is our very popular new interactive
programming featuring one of the daily
were our houses we hang out with you
each night 8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific all access members also get to
join us for live exclusive online q and
A's that's the Daily wires new
discussion feature available on both the
website and the daily wire app I can
tell you all access live gets a bizarre
there was some Chris Matthews singing
Queen last night I'll just say that's
the thing that happened on all access
live there is also charged our banks as
Nancy Pelosi so a few weird things
happen all access membership also
includes of course the singular
irreplaceable leftist here's tumbler
head on over to Daily wire comm slash
subscribe to join daily wires all-access
Club with the new membership or an
upgrade get 10% off with coupon code
Shapiro that is daily wire calm
slash subscribe also we should note that
when you are a daily Y remember you also
get all
bonus questions on things like Sunday
special this week's Sunday special
features Douglas Murray the great
columnist and author from Great Britain
who tells us about how coronavirus is
going over in Europe and European
perceptions of president Trump here's a
little bit of that he's unbelievable
race baiters he pretend they're anti
races who pretend that people can find
meaning in their life because of their
skin pigmentation find meaning in your
life definitely but don't think you're
gonna get it from your chromosomes it's
a really fun Sunday special Douglas a
great guy and that you should check it
out this Sunday by becoming a subscriber
you are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say the media is narrative here
which is that Andrew Cuomo did a great
job and Rhonda census was a disaster and
lockdown was a great idea but not
locking down is a terrible idea and
Sweden is horrible but states that lock
down are doing an amazing amazing job as
time progresses it becomes perfectly
obvious that all of this narrative was
just bullcrap and the fact there are so
many people who are willing to maintain
the narrative in the face of different
information is astonishing and good for
political for even recognizing the
Rhonda census has basically been screwed
over by the media I love the Washington
Post editorial today picture of Andrew
Cuomo says the staggering coronavirus
toll at nursing homes justifies extreme
measures ya think ya think some of us
have been saying this since the middle
of March that guess what a vastly
disproportionate number of people are
dying in nursing homes because this is a
disease that targets elderly people with
compromised immune systems and people
who have pre-existing conditions only
now are you beginning to realize hey
wait a second Andrew Cuomo is a crappy
governor and all of his little cute
stories with Chris Cuomo don't solve for
the problem that his state has lost more
people than any other state by probably
a factor of three at this point
according to the Washington Post
editorial board residents and staff of
nursing homes and other long-term care
facilities account for roughly half of
1% of the US population and more than a
third of the Cova 19 deaths that
justifies extreme measures by federal
and officials and states so far both of
box so they're going to try and blame
the feds for the fact that Andrew Cuomo
didn't shut down his own didn't shut
down his own nursing homes incredible
dr. deborah birx
said we really believe that all 1
million nursing home residents need to
be tested within the next two weeks as
well as the staff New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo who has ordered twice
weekly testing for nursing home staff in
his state is leading the way this is
like what what so then how bad is the
Washington Post editorial board they're
portraying Andrew Cuomo who blew this
thing worse than any governor in America
as the hero of the nursing home story
that it like yes I certainly trust these
people to make decisions for you and for
me and more than that I trust them to
provide us unbiased information so that
we can make our own decisions
so the frustration is reaching breaking
point here Dave Portenoy over at
barstool sports he he put out a video
yesterday that got six million views and
I gotta tell you there what he says here
is absolutely correct here is Dave
Portnoy
we've done what you've asked us to do if
you're that scared self Corona stay
inside the beds are open it doesn't kill
every I get it it's not a great option
there are no great options but you can't
just decimate the entire economy how is
that gonna work
we're staying inside till there's a cure
when did that become the game who said
we get the Cure that's not a guaranteed
so we're just done as humans get the
hell out a there's risk we're Americans
you have to take risk
hey this is correct and who's being
ripped up and down by the left yesterday
for us explain to me what's inaccurate
about this Joe Rogan yesterday says
listen I may have to leave California
because this is unlivable I can't tell
you how many friends I've taken calls
from in the last week or two who have
said exactly the same thing and you know
who can afford to leave California the
people who can afford to leave
California the people are getting
absolutely jacked are the people who are
losing their jobs and no matter how many
times Eric Garcetti promises you there
will be money to fill in your bank
account when all the people who can
afford to leave do ain't gonna be nobody
paying those bills here's Joe Rogan if
California continues to be this
restrictive yeah I don't know if this is
a good place to live first of all it's
extremely expensive the tax is here
ridiculous yeah and if they really say
that we can't do stand-up until 2022 or
something like that I might jet yeah I'm
not kidding yeah I'm not kidding this is
silly I don't need to be here the only
reason why I'm here is that I'm close to
people like you right a lot of my
friends live here stores here but if
they do they won't let us do the store
but we could do stand-up other places
why would we stay here okay and this is
correct
this is correct you are going to see
population movements people are gonna
they're gonna walk with their feet yeah
that's what's gonna happen you're gonna
see a big swell in population in states
that treated this thing the way it
should be treated namely in localized
fashion allowing individuals to exercise
therefore that I mean isn't that what
freedom is recognizing your own risk
reward ratios and then going out and
acting on them and that doesn't mean
that those risk reward ratios can't like
there are certain areas where
enforcement would be necessary so for
example I don't think that it is out of
the realm of possibility in the middle
of this pandemic without any real
solution if the goal is to slow the
spread such that you don't want to spike
over the healthcare system from local
officials to say if you are in a place
where you are going to be within six
feet of others you should be wearing a
face mask but I think
people are doing that anyway hey that's
my policy my policy has been every time
I go to the grocery store I put on a
face mask every time I go inside a
restaurants pick up food I put on a face
mask every time in my car by myself no
face masks when I'm walking around my
kids on the street no face masks because
why the hell would I wear a face mask
when there's nobody within a hundred
feet of me when I'm at the park with my
kids no face masks but that's called
people making individual risk reward
calculations and that's important but
here's the real agenda here for a lot of
people this is why this is this is where
the failures of the media to just
provide you information that allow you
to make decisions cross streams with the
partisan agenda and that is when you see
Democrats who an open fashion are
talking about using the pandemic to
radically reshift how American life is
going to work for the long haul
then it starts to feel like okay you
guys it's not even that you are just
ignorant and stupid and making these
policies that have nothing to do with
data that you shouting science at me
while telling Mannion to wear a mask
alone in my car or I need to mask up my
four-year-old son when were out on the
street a hundred feet from somebody else
that's not it's just you being ignorant
or terrible at your job
it's actually an agenda driven thing is
when you start saying the agenda out
loud so aoc always says that stupid show
he says the quiet part out loud I see
it's one thing that I love about a si
people have said if you could snap your
fingers and she wouldnt be on the
political scene would you make AOC go
away no AOC is fantastic
AOC always says the quiet part out loud
which is really important because then
it reveals the agenda so the illustrious
incomparable AOC the fresh-faced so
fresh so face so masky AOC she said
yesterday that we need to pay illegal
immigrants to stay away from work
because obviously we should be using
taxpayer dollars to support illegal
immigrants and then she added on because
undocumented workers pay billions more
than many corporations do which is just
insane okay she doesn't know if the hell
she's talking about she does know how
corporate taxes work she doesn't
understand that when Jeff Bezos when
Amazon pays Jeff Bezos but Jeff Bezos
pays money on his income she doesn't
understand how corporate structures work
so she thinks that corporations
ironically enough the same people who
say corporations are not people for
purposes of free speech free
corporations like people for purposes of
Taxation it doesn't matter to them that
if you and your friend organize an LLC
and then the profits flow through to you
and you pay an income tax you have now
paid tax on the money that flows through
the corporation she thinks the
corporation's like I said
a person that goes out for a burger or
something here's a Aussie saying dumb
crap about illegal immigrants and why we
should pay them by the way they pay
taxes I say this all the time because
people don't know they paid more taxes
more billions of dollars in taxes than
many corporations do so it just makes
sense but long term we address
healthcare housing wages and we need to
make sure that we do it in a way that's
not means-tested where there's all these
Swiss holes that people fall through and
their problems aren't addressed okay but
ALC went even further than this she says
listen not only do we need universal
health care that's just the first step
guys now that we've seen what a pandemic
can do let's just pay everybody and not
only is everybody a socialist during a
pandemic sisio see everybody should be a
socialist forever now who's gonna pay
for this she never explains if you
radically restructure the United States
why would anybody buy our bonds long
term she never explains but here is a
OSI explaining that she wants to
radically reshape how America works
long past the time to guarantee health
care in the United States that's level
one because when we get to a point where
we're struggling to afford a meal or
more struggling to to feel Economic
Security or material security it's
because all of these things are chipping
away at us it's health care it's student
loans it's rent it's the high cost of
housing and the high cost of living in
all of that it's immigration status and
so all of this is systemic
it's all systemic everything is systemic
it's not that we just got hit by the
worst black swuan in modern history it's
all systemic and therefore we need to
completely overthrow the system and then
you think I'm gonna listen to her about
lockdowns or maybe am I gonna think that
there's another agenda here Ilhan Oh
Martin and I on oppressively did the
same thing yesterday they said it's time
to cancel student loan debt why the hell
is it time to cancel student loan debt
that's long-term debt you took out why
is it time for me to pay for your
student loan bills why should I like why
I'm who's responsible enough to pay not
only my bills but pay my wife's student
loan bills I'm I was wise enough to put
my kids funds that I can put in a Utah
account right so that I'm saving for
their college education but bottom line
every crisis is an opportunity for folks
in the democratic party and so you're
not giving me information you're telling
me that I can't make an individual
decision but then I'm gonna have these
dolts making decisions for
I think not about economical read 19 you
should care of us information many folks
who still are in the process of getting
their unemployment benefits people who
are graduating without any foresight on
to what their future looks like we need
relief bills that put the people first
and put the people first by eliminating
the debt and eliminating the worry of
putting money back in their pockets oh
it so magically magically is just going
to appear yeah these people should
definitely set policy this is this is
Trump's campaign by the way Trump's
campaign as these lockdowns end is as
more Americans recognize that they're
gonna have to make their own individual
risk calculations Trump's campaign here
is actually a fairly strong one no the
Democrats are gonna try and campaign on
Trump botched this thing he did such a
terrible job but Trump being able to
campaign against people who obviously
want to restrict your ability to make
your own decisions is gonna be a strong
line here's Trump yesterday saying
people would like their freedom back
please and this is right if this
campaign comes down to Democrats
basically saying you don't get an in
freedom we're gonna tell you to lock
down forever but we'll sign you a check
and president Trump saying you know what
most Americans would like to have their
freedom back and we're talking November
guys it's been fun it's the middle of
May try this again in six months six
months you think people are gonna watch
it people are gonna watch them for six
more weeks it's not going to happen so
people in government better get with the
program and start recommending policies
that are justifiable you want people to
do responsible things recommend to them
justifiable data-driven policy don't
recommend to them that they're just out
there to strangle grandma cuz it ain't
true and people who are saying it don't
have to worry about feeding their kids
the people who are saying it don't have
to worry about losing their life savings
in their business the people who are
saying that are not the ones who are
suffering right now the people who are
most Pro lock down seem to be the ones
who are suffering the least right now
and that is in and that is an eminently
ugly way of promoting a lockdown again
most Americans if they are told right
now that their neighbors are going to
take care and their neighbors are going
to be responsible I think that deposed
show that most Americans are ready to
get back to work and they're ready to
get back to work in responsible fashion
I don't want to hear any more polls
about lock down versus complete opening
nobody's talking about that no one not
in Texas not in Florida not South Dakota
nowhere all righty let's get to some
things that I hate so the entire
Democratic candidacy for 2020 the entire
Joe Biden candidacy is reliant on the
notion that President Trump blew the
cover 19 in response and this is leading
to some rather extraordinary rather
extraordinary messaging from the left
okay so act blue which is a democratic
super PAC they have an account called
Biden war room just like Trump has Trump
war room and it's a super PAC outside of
the Trump campaign that Biden war room
is a super PAC outside of the Biden
campaign and they put out a tweet today
that really is full-scale disgusting and
truly awful okay it says nothing would
make Pope at 19 happier than oil for
Trump first of all cover 19 is does not
have an attitude cover 19 is a deadly
disease follow Biden war room if you're
ready for Joe Biden to beat Trump like a
drum in November then says breaking news
Cova 19 endorses Trump for a second term
provided a sanctuary country from the
virus to spread really cuz I'm pretty
sure that he was the one who's trying to
shut down travel created a new hot spots
by encouraging large gatherings you know
who else did that Andrew Cuomo Nancy
Pelosi helped virus grow by calling it a
hoax when he knew it wasn't he never
called the virus a hoax he said the
media coverage was a hoax
he never said the virus was a hoax that
is a lie it's a for Pinocchio live from
the Washington Post
but Biden war room is basically saying
that the virus endorses President Trump
that's pretty disgusting so your entire
campaign apparently is going to be that
Trump is is screwing up the Cova 19
response in fact today trending on
Twitter was this hashtag Trump has no
plan okay well what's your plan no one
is no one is actually presenting a plan
all I'm hearing from you is screaming at
Trump and every time Trump presents a
plan you just yell at him by the way the
CDC released a set of guidelines for
going back to work the guidelines are
too restrictive the guidelines are too
restrictive there are guidelines today
that say that should you consider
opening will you be consistent with
applicable state and local orders are
you ready to protect employees at
higher risk for severe illness if any of
those are know then do not open are the
recommended health and safety actions in
place encouraging social distancing and
enhancing spacing between employees
including physical barriers changing
layout of workspaces encouraging
telework considering modifying traveling
commuting practices if the answer to any
of these are no then you have to meet
the safeguard first and then you have to
have an ongoing monitoring system in
place developing and implementing
procedures who check for signs and
symptoms of employees daily upon arrival
as feasible
what the hell does that even mean and
like that's not going to work it
couldn't even do it at the White House
but are they putting forth plan they're
putting forth plans it's just that there
is no good plan for a pandemic
there's no good plan for a pandemic but
that's that is the the idea here from
from Team Biden meanwhile Joe Biden
literally cannot string a sentence
together
so if I'm if I'm supposed to believe
that Joe Biden is going to provide the
steady strong leadership that Donald
Trump has failed to provide you're gonna
need to do better than Joe Biden talking
to pre-recorded messages he did an
interview yesterday where the
interviewer played him is on MSNBC with
lawrence O'Donnell lawrence O'Donnell
played him a tape of a question and
because Joe Biden is not with us he
passed away it seems several years ago
Joe Biden tries to answer the caller as
though the caller is live on air because
he he's not with us anymore I mean this
is like this is the steady durable
leadership you're looking for this guy
right - not bad everyone every so often
one co19 is bad let me know he said it's
bad Wow amazing and then he gets on TV
and the dude doesn't even know when he's
talking to a live human being because he
hasn't been one for a while here's Joe
Biden I want to open it up to our town
hall component and get a question from a
voter this first question mr. vice
president's from a voter in California
let's listen to this okay Vice President
Biden
my name is Navid hi I'm from San Mateo
California and thank you so much for
allowing me to participate in this town
hall with you when I'm making a pledge
bad quote from the theme I regard that
you always recite good times good times
by the way yesterday
Biden confused the Paycheck Protection
Act with personal protective equipment
as well I mean the man is gaffing like
every few seconds it's pretty amazing in
the main
it's gonna matter lawrence whether or
not between now and then this president
has used his powers and used the
organizational ability that the White
House had that the president has to make
sure we have enough PPP those those
protective gear for this second wave if
there's going to be that second wave
which is predictable and the good news
for Joe Biden is that the media will
protect him no matter what it doesn't
matter that he can't string a sentence
together it doesn't matter that his
record has been fairly abysmal it none
of that matters because Joe Biden has
the media on his side so for example Joe
Biden yesterday he was asked
specifically about Michael Flynn because
it turns out that Joe Biden was one of
the people who requested the unmasking
of Michael Flynn now it's not illegal so
request the unmasking of somebody if you
are in the executive branch it is
however a pretty good indicator that you
were involved in the decision-making
regarding Michael Flynn here was Joe
Biden dodging questions on it yesterday
mr. vice president what was your
involvement in the investigation of
Michael Flynn and the FBI investigation
of Michael Flint I was never apart or
had any knowledge of any in criminal
investigation into Flynn while I was in
office period not one single time okay
nobody said that you had knowledge of
the criminal investigation although it
is weird that you were talking with
Barack Obama about Flynn's conversation
before the DOJ even knew about a
courtesy of the FBI okay but the good
news is again the media will carry water
for Biden no matter what there's a piece
in The Daily Beast titled the new supid
CBS reporter driving Democrats and some
of her own colleagues crazy and it's all
about the evils of Catherine Herridge
because Catherine Herridge of course is
their reporter for CBS who used to work
at Fox News and so now there's an entire
piece about how she is pushing GOP
talking points why because that's
exactly the Biden campaign said
yesterday is incredible to watch as a
message is created inside the Biden
campaign and then promptly repeated by
members of the mainstream media even if
it's a message about how other members
of the media are bad here's another
example New York Times has a piece today
by Nick Horace ante and Maggie Haberman
and here is what it says the first wave
of loan promised negative ads from the
Trump campaign began this week in
caustic form flooding Facebook pages and
television screens in swing states with
harsh harsh messages that make
unfounded inferences about Joseph
Biden's mental state I don't think you
have to make an unfounded inference
about his mental state all you got to do
is watch the man for more than six
minutes and paint the presumptive
Democratic nominee as too friendly to
the Chinese government in May alone
the Trump campaign has spent or reserved
about seven million dollars on
television airtime in local markets
fueling negative ads that repeat
xenophobic tropes regarding the Chinese
origin of the coronavirus is an area
actually just blatantly labeling Trump a
racist on the basis that he points out
that this virus came from China just
pick it and pick up that water and carry
it man this is this is Jack and Joe go
up the hill carrying water for Joe Biden
and that is impressive stuff impressive
stuff from the New York Times I
definitely trust these people
definitely definitely trust these people
and no the Biden campaign needs all the
help them get because this campaign is a
disaster area and it's gonna be even
more of a disaster area if Joe Biden
continues to message that the country is
supposed to stay shut down until the end
of time okay time for one more quick
thing that I hate so remember that time
when the ACLU stood for the idea that
you have civil rights no matter your
political perspective remember that time
when they stood for the idea that people
had a right to due process and right to
free speech not anymore
I'm old enough to remember when the ACLU
was sort of the de facto Organization
for I may disagree with what you say but
you have every right to say it
now the ACL u--'s message is if we don't
like you then we are going to sue you so
that you've just become like every other
left-wing legal agitprop association
here's the latest indicator according to
NBC News Education Secretary Betsy DeVos
has revised federal guidelines on how
sexual assault allegations should be
handled on college and k12 campuses are
the target of a federal lawsuit filed
Thursday claiming that the changes would
inflict significant harm on victims and
dramatically undermine their civil
rights the suit filed on behalf of for
advocacy groups for people who have been
sexually assaulted is the first that
seeks to block the Education
Department's new provisions before they
go into effect on August 14th the rules
championed by DeVos effectively
bolstered the rights of due process for
those accused of sexual assault and
harassment allowing for live hearings in
cross-examinations it's what agency
officials say was lacking during the
Obama administration to protect all
students under title 9 and by the way
federal court says that said the same
federal courts had said that the Obama
era rules on title 9 it basically said
if you're accused you can't
confront your accuser you can't
cross-examine your accuser you have to
take the allegations as factually true
that those rules did not meet with the
requirements for due process so Betsy
DeVos changed the rules to me what the
requirements would do process now the
ACLU is filing a lawsuit against due
process the suit filed in the US
District Court in Maryland by the ACLU
and struck struck and levan LLP says
this new federal efforts weaken title 9
makes it more difficult for victims of
sexual harassment or sexual assault to
continue their education and needlessly
comes amid a global pandemic so the ACLU
has now completely shifted its
perspective the suit according to rhea
tobacco mar director of the ACLU Women's
Rights Project challenges title 9
regulations that will redefine sexual
misconduct and narrower terms as
misconduct so severe pervasive and
objectively offensive that is an eyes a
person equal access to the school's
education program or activity tobacco
mar argued it created a double standard
for how schools must treat sexual
discrimination complaints compared to
how they handle allegations of racial
national origin and disability
discrimination well actually no that's
just what sexual harassment law has
always been severe pervasive and
objectively offensive it can't just be
you perceived something as bad and now
we ban students but the key here is not
even the argument cuz the arguments bad
the key here is that the ACLU is
pursuing this argument which just
demonstrates have the left's perspective
on rights themselves has shifted it used
to be that the left in America relied on
the grid on the framework of Rights in
order to make its arguments so the ACLU
is to say listen we may not like Nazis
marching through Skokie but American
rights mean that you somehow sometimes
you have to just suck it up and
understand that people who suck have the
same rights that you do and they will
exercise them in ways you don't like but
so long as they're not punching you in
the face that is not a violation of your
rights
the ACLU used to stand up for the
proposition that rights were
non-discriminatory that rights
themselves were a good that everybody
had their inalienable rights where a
like the ACLU agreed with the right on
this and with libertarians on this now
the ACLU has bought into the left-wing
Trump that rights are inherently unequal
that the right to free speech is unequal
and bad why because the rights of free
speech might offend some people because
there are more powerful people and less
powerful people and so if everyone has
the rights of free speech the people who
are most likely to benefit from the
lower rights of free speech are the
people who are the most powerful
and so now the ACLU has bought into what
Professor air Barmera Q's one suggestion
was an idea of repressive tolerance that
in order for true free speech to
flourish we have to silence the most
powerful members of society so that
everybody else gets a chance to talk
but it's this bizarre version of Rights
that you see sort of imitated by crazy
people like Sara au when she will have
white privilege sessions at people's
dining room tables and tell the white
people to shut up and people will pay
her for this privilege because she'll
say well you don't get to talk because
of your privilege there's what you see
on college campuses a lot this idea that
any right that is equally applied can
never actually be equal it is actually
an application of inequality and the
deepening of inequality
same thing with economic rights if we
say you have property rights that only
helps people who are more rich that only
helps people's property through property
rights would be removing rights to
property for people who are more
powerful and richer and giving them to
people who have less power in our poorer
now understand that's no longer a right
that is now redistributed of coercive
tactic but that's what the ACLU is now
standing for they're basically saying
due process should be redistributed due
process which used to be a right for
everybody and whether you were rich or
poor you got to process whether you were
black or white you got to process this
is what the ACLU used to stand for male
or female due process now the ACLU says
if we have due process it could hurt
women who have to confront their accuser
and therefore we need to have no due
process for men but yes due process for
women if this is the end of any
semblance of an American polity you
cannot have a country where the rights
do not equally apply you cannot have a
country where we decide how the law
applies based on race sex or class if
you do that it's no longer law now it is
just an arbitrary metric of which groups
are in power politically hey by the way
it was really bad when people used to
apply law unequally I think we were all
in agreement on that correct Jim Crow
was evil laws applied unequally to men
and women evil and yet now you have the
ACLU openly stumping for that oh but
it's pretty incredible and it
demonstrates the mentality shift that
has happened in this country I talk
about all this at length in my new book
how to destroy America in three easy
steps that's gonna be coming out in the
end of July but it is again indicative
of a mindset shift that is incredibly
dangerous for the future of the country
alrighty we will be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content otherwise
we'll see you here Monday I'm bent
repair this is the Ben Shapiro show the
Ben Shapiro show is produced by Colton
Haas directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling assistant director Pavel white
house key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 you know the
Matt Walsh show it's not just another
show about about politics I think there
are enough of those already out there we
talk about culture because culture
drives politics and it drives everything
else so my main focus is our life family
faith those are fundamental and that's
what this show is about I hope you'll
give it a listen